notre société d'aujourd'hui elle te fait
peur elle veut faire peur par bien des
aspects par exemple le lynchage
médiatique on lèche on lâche et on lâche
on lâche tu sais pas pourquoi un exemple
concret bah c'est pas le mal c'était
déjà mort avant le moindre procédé tu
vois pas le mal il y a pas de conseils
du tout il est mort qui prennent une
voiture sous l'emprise de substance
illicite c'est très mauvais bien sûr
mais c'est pas à moi le juger il y a toi
il y a des procès il y a des juges il y
a des toute la machine judiciaire pour
ça j'ai envie de l'aider tellement il
est lâché
alors oui mais c'est pas très mauvais il
dit c'est très mauvais d'avoir pris une
voiture c'est criminel délictuel
honteuse scandaleux il y a des victimes
il y a un bébé qui est né quelques
minutes puis qui est mort il y a une
poursuite pour homicide involontaire on
peut pas dire comme ça il est lynché
comme à la caverne je trouve que Julien
Lepers minimise totalement le drame pas
du tout
on va dire ça moi je suis contre le d'un
chef médiatique quand on sait pas ce qui
s'est passé mais là c'est très clair
Pierre Palmade il a pris de la drogue il
a conduit en ayant pris de la drogue il
a décimé une famille il a bousillé une
famille pardon mais qu'est-ce qu'on s'en
fout qu'il y a un âge médiatique le
lynchage il va durer aller quelques
semaines quelques mois parce que ça
intéresse les gens après ce sera terminé
par contre oui dans un an deux ans on en
parlera plus par contre pour la famille
les séquelles elles sont à vie donc on
est un linge médiatique autour de
Palmade qui est coupable c'est avéré on
s'en fout pardon on s'en fout la statue
de la liberté elle en pense quoi
je suis un peu d'accord c'est à dire que
malheureusement on sait ce qu'il a fait
de toute façon alors maintenant moi j'ai
juste un tout petit truc dans le dans la
tête je me dis imaginons il y a pas
encore eu les les choses techniques la
languette technique imaginons qu'on
aperçoivent que un frein à lâcher ou je
ne sais quoi donc voilà donc on l'a
quand même voilà
c'est quand même ça mais c'est tellement
atteint parce que c'est un achat voilà
mérité et il a raison il est mort
comment voulez-vous qu'il se qui se le
terme mort est très mal choisi
j'ai un peu enquêté les chéris je vous
dis
s'il n'est pas entendu et si apparemment
il serait il serait pas remis en liberté
mais pour l'instant oui mais pour le
moment il n'est plus détenu
c'est pas plus j'espère que c'est pas ça
on me dit si c'est ça c'est aussi
peut-être parce que l'AVC était
extrêmement violent attention aussi
c'est ce que disent également les
médecins et des personnes qui sont voilà
qui sont dans l'affaire un peu voilà des
des des policiers qui sont dans
l'affaire notamment les copains du speed
non mais c'est vrai
aujourd'hui c'est que que ce soit
Bourdin Ary Abittan Pierre Palmade il y
a bien l'exemple aussi horrible
attention de prendre
le cas de l'horreur qui s'est passé je
dis qu'aujourd'hui si tu es une
célébrité de toute manière maintenant
c'est les États-Unis à partir du moment
où tu es tu es mis en lumière là-dessus
c'est fini t'es condamné c'est terminé
le procès n'existera même pas que tu
gagnes tu perdes c'est fini pour toi
c'est ce que je voulais dire ce gar est
horrible évidemment je compare pas
d'autres choses mais une célébrité
aujourd'hui à partir du moment on a dit
son nom c'est terminé dans ce cas-là il
y en a plein qui alors je vais dire Luc
Besson il a été relaxé apparemment
voilà c'est sur internet
c'est pas comparable ça marche quand on
sait pas là on sait les filles sont là
ils sont hyper dessus il y a un bébé qui
est mort qu'est-ce que tu veux faire on
va pas pleurer pour lui parce qu'il est
connu et qu'on parle de lui plus qu'un
anonyme ça marche quand c'est des
affaires c'est difficile de prouver
l'effet là les filles sont prouver
établis ils la même reconnu qu'est-ce
que tu veux faire ne pas en parler non
c'est pas ne pas en parler on dit juste
que pour le moment tu sais ce qu'on fait
on attend qu'il soit jugé et quand il
sera jugé pour le moment mais l'autre
jour c'est ce qui est Dupont-Moretti il
a dit chemise en examen et il a dit pour
le moment je suis mise en examen je suis
présumé innocent pour le moment
il a pas fait ça il a dit je suis mis en
examen je suis présumé le son
[Rires]
mais encore une fois j'ai la raison si
ça se trouve l'arbre à cama lâché la
voiture on sait jamais pour l'instant
il est innocent Béatrice de toute façon
c'est un sujet de société c'est normal
que la société civile sans en parler
il faut mettre sur la table le problème
des drogues le problème de l'alcool et
des drogues au volant ça va faire
avancer la société et oui
malheureusement prière Palmade a fait ce
qu'il a fait et doit prendre ses
responsabilités il faut arrêter de le
déresponsabiliser et de l'excuser
maintenant il sera jugé effectivement on
verra si la justice le combat et comment
elle le condamne mais on doit pouvoir en
parler on doit pouvoir s'exprimer sur
ces sujets et effectivement par rapport
à la famille c'est un scandale pour moi
qui soit qui soit relâché Julien Lepers
est déjà mort selon lui il faut arrêter
d'en parler qu'est-ce que tu en penses
il a raison mais médiatique déjà il est
déjà mort comment Bertrand Cantat
comment il va remonter sur scène pour
faire rire tout le monde sait qu'il y a
ça il y a ça en tête et tu sais c'est
les gens tu peux pas leur empêcher de
s'emparer une situation il y a un drame
c'est Twitter chacun dit ce qu'il veut
chacun dit c'est le tribunal populaire
bien sûr qu'il est pas jugé et vous
dites ouais la voiture la voiture même
si la voiture de toute façon il a
conduit en état d'ivresse et là tu
conduis sous drogue c'est tu sais c'est
comme tu as dit toi il y a pas longtemps
tu as dit ouais j'ai conduit dix ans
bourré moi j'ai jamais conduit disons
bourré moi j'ai dit quelquefois je
partais en tournée avec deux verres de
trop sur les réseaux sociaux je me suis
fait massacrer comme ça c'est les
réseaux sociaux j'ai laissé j'ai c'est
comme ça tu m'as envoyé un saut de de
gens qui ont dit ouais tu es
complètement taré disons avec alcool
c'est comme ça quand tu passes à la télé
Palma dit passe à la télé il a fait des
spectacles pour moi je suis le mot est
dur ce qui a dit Julien Courbet Julien
Julien Lepers le mot est dur mais pour
moi il est et oui il est mort
médiatiquement il est mort comment il va
faire pour remonter moi personnellement
comment il va faire pour remonter sur ça
je sors de prison je change de pays j'ai
vu aux États-Unis ou ailleurs tu peux
pas dans la rue en France France c'est
fini Delphine en fait c'est ça en fait
ce qu'il explique c'est que si ça avait
été Pierre Paul Jacques au bout d'un
moment effectivement c'est horrible tu
fais ta peine et après peut-être tu
essayes difficilement de refaire ta vie
un peu dans l'anonymat tu changes
peut-être de ville pour que les gens ne
te reconnaissent pas le problème c'est
que il n'aura plus jamais lui la
possibilité de faire quoi que ce soit
celui qui va n'est-ce pas travailler
même pas d'avoir un enfant concret c'est
lui qui l'a décidé
mais dans un autre cas si ça avait été
Pierre Paul Jacques et ben le garçon ça
aurait été exactement la même chose mais
n'empêche que dans 20 ans 30 ans la
personne aurait pu quand même reprendre
une vie
certaine lambda si c'était lambda il y a
plein de cas et les familles qui nous
regardent il aurait il y a plein de gens
qui changent de vie lui c'est fini ils
vont même pas en prison
d'alcool ou sous cannabis ou sous drogue
ou soukam ils ne vont pas en prison là
on veut qu'il aille en prison parce que
c'est Pierre Palmade et parce qu'il a
dit qu'il assumerait c'est les juges
vont faire leur travail mais tu dis 20
ans jamais personne après 20 ans pour je
pense pas je pense pas c'est vrai qu'il
est mort il y a il peut rappeler à faire
regarde effectivement tu évoqué en
faisant lapsus Julien Courbet mais
Julien Courbet raconté l'histoire de son
papa exactement papa était fauché par
quelqu'un qui était sous l'emprise de
l'alcool et il a même pas fait un jour
de détention provoque un jour papa on
est décédé carrément décédé et peut-être
que cet homme-là non seulement pas fait
des tensions professeur n'est pas de
prison du tout
et il a pu certainement reprendre sa vie
professionnelle après ce que ne pourra
pas faire c'est sûr que le statut homme
connu ou femme connue change la donne
effectivement une fois qu'il aura payé
ça sa dette si voilà si tenté que ce
soit évidemment possible s'il était
bouché architecte ou je sais pas
électricien il pourrait refaire son
travail lui Pierre Palmade il est
condamné à vie c'est vrai que le
lynchage médiatique a été très violent
mais moi je pense comme Béatrice je
pense que ça sert aussi de lanceur
d'alerte si ce fait divers ici quand on
a parlé on est regardé par des jeunes ça
permet un jeune de pas prendre de la
commune pas prendre son scooter après
avoir pris de la coke ou taper des
drogues ou des choses comme ça et ben
moi je trouve que il faut en parler et
voilà même si il est aussi que le cobaye
de cette histoire et ben c'est pas grave
je trouve que c'est très important d'en
parler parce que c'est un fait divers
qui peut faire aussi bouger les choses
et sur la justice et sur la récidive et
sur le voilà parce que c'est une
célébrité quand on ne célébrité on a
énormément d'avantages on est content de
prendre plein d'argent on est content
d'être connu on est content qu'on ne
donne des tables au restaurant La quand
ça va pas faut accepter que ça aille pas
bien dans le mauvais sens aussi et
pardon mais il y a d'autres métiers qui
être connu que tu Maurice peut-être qui
peut se réinsérer professionnellement
d'ailleurs effectivement mais pourquoi
pas
autre chose et pourquoi il est mort
excusez-moi moi en tout cas je n'ai pas
envie de pleurer pour lui c'est toujours
mais rien parce que tu es toujours
monsieur démagogie quand on parle
célébrités
au monde il a frappé une femme droguée
et il l'a laissé mourir sans appeler
même les les secours elle aurait pu être
pour moi c'est beaucoup plus grave il a
pris 7 ans c'est rien
Cantat mec pris 7 ans de sa vie sa vie
elle redémarre derrière personne ne le
sait tu vois ce que je veux dire voilà
le poids il a failli faire de refaire
des concerts mais il a failli et il
réessaye il aura perdu 7 ans de sa vie
pour avoir massacré une femme tu te
rends compte que je veux dire et ça
compagne sans doute campagne c'est
suicidé aussi hein
donc donc arrête avec les revers de la
médailles et les machins c'est la raison
les avantages
il a raison quand tu es quand tu es
connu tu es quand même un exemple après
que tu fasses des conneries tout seul
chez toi très bien là il y a des
conséquences et effectivement il est
mort il est impardonnable quoi qu'il
fasse quoi qu'il fasse est-ce que tu as
dit une phrase qui est une bêtise à la
base pardon de te le dire ou quand on
est connu on n'est pas un exemple pour
les gens
on fait un métier on est chroniqueurs de
télé moi je fais un métier et je rentre
chez moi le soir parfois je prends la
bus RATP parfois je bois trop de potes
parfois je suis un mec normal comme tout
le monde je fais un bidon tu as signé un
contrat tu dois être exemplaire dans ton
contrat c'est marqué un comportement qui
n'est pas à la boîte c'est par rapport à
la boîte quand toutes les boîtes tout de
suite mais par rapport à vous bah
laissez-moi par rapport à son public
tu dois avoir un bon comportement c'est
même pas
nous compare pas à Palmade qui est un
artiste Johnny il a il a il l'a dit à
tout le monde que il avait eu des
problèmes avec la drogue avec l'alcooly
reste une icône personne
[Musique]
dans ta phrase les chars doivent être
des exemples pardon mais il y a plein de
stars qu'on adulte nous tous
les Rolling Stones
en quoi dans quoi notre
de vouloir protéger les stars les VIP
oui ce sont des artistes je suis désolé
tu as merdé tu as fait un truc très
grave si tu te retrouves dans la merde
et bah tu te débrouilles tu as qu'à
aller bosser c'est pas c'est pas même si
c'est je veux dire voilà arrêtez de
vouloir parce que vous parlez de l'après
c'est ça en fait bah oui après
mistinguette
je suis d'accord il y a des gens qui
en fait le truc c'est que lui c'est il a
eu malheureusement il est rentré dans
quelqu’un il a brisé une famille mais
tous les gens qui se droguent et qui
boivent toute leur vie comme Johnny je
suis désolé ils sont mis en situation
ils ont pris des risques et fait prendre
des risques aujourd'hui
on a pas besoin donc elle lève elle lève
un lièvre non mais non c'est déjà c'est
sous le verre le vin lièvre cette fois
est à Mykonos mais c'est pas on peut pas
lever un livre non on soulève par en
dessous si tu le prends par là tu
m'emmerdes Gilles non mais on est bien
d'accord que parce que c'est pas très
clair ce que vous disiez Mathieu on est
bien d'accord pour moi Bertrand Cantat
il ne doit plus jamais chanter de sa vie
on est d'accord là-dessus et ben moi je
vais vous le dire Pierre Palmade il ne
doit plus jamais faire rire de sa vie je
suis désolé j'espère qu'il ne fera plus
de spectacle je ne vois pas comment un
jour même dans 10 ans 20 ans il peut de
nouveau faire rire on est d'accord
c'est c'est normal et c'est normal il
est déjà mort vous êtes d'accord il est
déjà mort si sous-entend qu'il ne pourra
plus faire rire là-dessus je suis
d'accord avec lui et je ne veux plus
qu'il fasse rire parce que moi il ne me
fera plus jamais rire il y a une
nouvelle lecture du personnage
Mathieu oui parce que il y a aussi des
choses un peu étonnant c'est quoi le
lièvre que tu voulais me soumettre
il y a des choses ici un petit peu
tenantes pourquoi on pardonne à certains
et pas d'autres par exemple Palmade il a
fait une connerie avec la drogue c'est
dégueulasse c'est dégueulasse mais c'est
vrai que les stars les Rockstar mais que
on aime bien c'est un petit côté on veut
pas voir Madonna faire des crêpes
Madonna elle se drogue c'est machin
pas de conséquences attention attention
de de de de gentillesse et de fantaisie
merci d'empathie avec toutes les
rockstars qui montent
n'importe quel Rockstar mais oui
on va on va dire que c'est inadmissible
de là tu dis des bêtises alors
je repose le livre
math aussi c'est que la célébrité
évidemment que ça double tranchant mais
la célébrité par exemple ça fait avancer
les causes one Stein quand il y a le
scandale winstin Hervé washteen Le
balance ton porc le mytho et tout ça en
fait ça avance aussi si ça avait été
monsieur tout le monde ça n'aurait pas
avancé la cause à l'avance la libération
de la parole elle avance parce que c'est
quelqu'un de mondialement connu à
Hollywood du coup les actrices pas les
journalistes parlent tu vois tu
comprends ce que je veux dire donc oui
effectivement il est connu donc il est
forcément cuit c'est mort il frappera
d'ailleurs il en prie normal les gens
connus doivent être exemplaires pour
vous comme l'a dit non évidemment
comme tout le monde
encore plus exemples sauf que quand ils
sont dans la lumière les femmes ça
libèrent la parole et les femmes on
parle donc effectivement oui c'est
double peine mais tant pis et quand
Julien Lepers dit qu'il est mort il est
mort médiatiquement le bébé il est mort
tout court voilà il est mort tout court
et Pierre Palma je suis désolé faut
aussi rappeler un truc il était pas non
plus au summum de sa carrière ça faisait
quelques années que ça tournait un peu
moins bien il avait fait ma singer il
avait besoin d'argent c'est sorti
partout il avait des finances compliqués
donc au bout d'un moment quand tu es
dans la merde tu c'est en général c'est
pas que tu es au top de ta carrière donc
quand tu es dans la merde
je connais des personnalités qui étaient
en haut de la fiche il y a 20 ans 30 ans
qui aujourd'hui bosse comme serveur et
ben comme tout le monde c'est comme ça
on va pas pleurer pour lui poser une
question tout à l'heure il a demandé à
Géraldine est-ce qu'on doit être un
exemple Géraldine a dit oui je te pose
la question en quoi en quoi toi par
exemple tu dois être un exemple
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que tu je dis
pas ça je dis tu dois tout faire bien si
jamais je fais une connerie comme Pierre
Palmade
tu fais pas de bêtises mais si ça
m'arrive un jour je je ne pleurnicherai
pas si je dois être obligé de retrouver
un travail normal comme tout le monde
c'est la vie
normale
des impôts comme ça
on veut leur donner un totem d'immunité
parce que c'est des sports
c'est le showbiz ou rien mais il y a une
autre vie il y a pas que le showbiz là
c'est les films les gens peuvent aller
aussi
n'importe quoi tu crois que tu
t'appelles après tu peux devenir
coiffeuse devrait faire mais elle peut
pas les gens te parler un peu il a
raison ok donc tu crois que tu lui
dévisse bon il
faudrait-il
dévissait tu crois quoi que nundai il
peut ouvrir une épicerie ville d'accord
une fois dans ta vie tu ne dois plus
être sur des plateaux télés faire le
bruit
ça commence
si demain il ferme le rideau il éteint
la lumière vous allez faire quoi ah oui
je sais pas moi je suis animateur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on va bosser et comme tout le monde et
c'est normal et c'est là que j'ai
l'impression que pardon mais ce milieu
dans ce milieu les gens sont
complètement hors-sol enfin pardon mais
c'est pas non plus le bail d'aller
travailler de faire un travail normal
enfin qu'est-ce qu'il y a de on dit oh
il va quand même pas faire serveur et
alors mais qu'est-ce qu'on s'en fout
c'est de tout le monde fait ça tout le
monde travaille parce que ça demande à
travailler c'est des mots quand tu as
été en business en avion ou tu as un
Lamborghini tu vois vendeur chez Zara
l'année prochaine
c'est pas vrai si t'es obligé si t'as
pas le choix c'est ta vie à pleurniche
parce que si tu es un peu intelligent
déjà tu mets de côté tu pars du principe
que c'est un métier qui est fragile moi
ce que j'ai fait qui est fragile qui est
dangereux pour toi ça va être très
fragile d'ailleurs voilà moi je n'ai
jamais vu
j'ai
au moins j'aurais pas à faire la
Quinzaine du reblochon dans un
Intermarché j'ai un petit peu d'argent
on me l'a proposé pour toi c'est vrai la
Quinzaine du roblochon madame
blochon c'est quoi les prisons de dire
franchement si on arrête j'ai aucun
problème soit je redeviens journaliste
avec tes copains
ce ne sont pas mes copains
avec tes amis ce ne sont pas mes amis
non plus mais je ferai autre chose je
trouverai de nouveaux amis je fais autre
chose et vous Mathieu vous êtes esclave
de la célébrité de la lumière
contrairement à nous à moi par exemple
c'est ça votre problème je sais que vous
vous ne pourriez pas vous en passer mais
c'est votre personnage qui est construit
un siège le respect mais moi je pourrais
totalement m'en passer
ta vie à commenter celle des autres tu
feras autre chose quoi
et aucun problème je suis animateur de
centre de loisirs comme j'ai fait je
vais trier les pommes de terre il y a
énormément de job en ce moment je fais
n'importe quoi je vais créer dans une
fois mais c'est vrai les pommes de terre
aide-moi
de porter des trucs de vie on a Rungis
bien sûr il va déménager des pianos j'y
ert une ferme demain il a raison je
crois pas trop ferme demain je suis
spécialiste en ramassage 2 quand il y a
150 poules
[Applaudissements]
quelles sont les dernières infos là sur
l'affaire Palmade alors sur l'affaire
Palma il y a donc vendredi la réunion de
la chambre de l'instruction d'accord
on appelle on verra si le procureur
entendu très franchement ce serait une
grosse surprise qui redevient un détenu
là c'est une victoire importante que ces
avocats ont obtenu a priori ils ne
devrait pas retourner en prison d'autant
qu'effectivement pour le moment les
médecins sont complètement opposés à ce
qu'il a dans une vraie cellule donc
première victoire de ces avocats qui
devrait se poursuivre on verra je peux
me tromper mais normalement vendredi il
devrait être libre sous contrôle
judiciaire voilà tu veux savoir Cyril
quel est le vrai
sous contrôle judiciaire avec un compte
véritable avantage des gens riches la
célébrité c'est la richesse c'est qu'ils
peuvent se payer des avocats extrêmement
doués extrêmement cher
Palma dit il a plus
il a quand même un peu d'argent
très cher justement ils vont ils vont
vers des anonymes pour pouvoir être dans
la lumière quand c'est des personnes
justement
sur l'affaire sur les affaires
médiatiques comme ça il y a beaucoup
d'avocation spécifique y compris
gratuitement pour justement être dans la
lumière y compris déjà gratuitement les
victimes mais pas pour faire Palmade
hein
c'est à dire qu'il est ruiné parce que
les gens qui nous écoutent il y a un
appartement dans dans le centre de Paris
qui vaut pas comment il le loue
l'appartement alors j'ai rien dit et à
la maison à saignant
donc arrêtez de me dire qui doit 250000
euros il est ruiné parce que là la
maison coûte un million 3 donc les gens
les gens à un moment donné ils font les
calculs donc il est pas totalement il
est pas totalement ruiné il a dit qu'il
assumerait quand il y a eu l'accident
les premiers mots qu'il a dit c'est je
vais assumer alors il va assumer il faut
arrêter de se cacher derrière des
excuses ah mais c'est rien c'est un
million cinq ans c'est beaucoup un
million ah bah oui il y a 50 ans les
50000 €, 50 millions c'est énorme les 50
000 tu payes l'avocat